this episode of real engineering is
brought to you by breed a problem
solving website that teaches you to
think like an engineer
next time you're near the ocean listen
closely to the waves that sound you hear
that's wasted energy the energy from
waves tides and currents known
collectively as ocean energy is a
massive resource just waiting to be
tapped the total energy available along
the American continental shelf could
potentially provide roughly half of the
current total US energy supply with an
estimated 250 terawatt-hours per year
for the West Coast 160 for the East
Coast 60 for the Gulf of Mexico 620 for
Alaska 80 for Hawaii and 20 for Puerto
Rico harnessing all that energy while
transporting ash to population centers
and finding suitable locations along the
coast that will not affect coastline
ecosystems and property values would be
a difficult if not impossible task but
if we can find a suitable way to harness
the power of the tides and waves off our
coasts it could provide the final push
needed to convert our grid to a 100%
renewable system there are many methods
to gain energy from the sea wave power
is created as the wind pushes the
surface of the ocean ocean currents
provide power driven predominantly by
wind and heat from the Sun some systems
have even utilized the differences in
salinity between rivers and seas to
produce electricity
however today we're going to investigate
one of the most promising technologies
in this sector tidal energy it has huge
potential in the renewable energy market
thanks to its predictable and consistent
availability tides change four times a
day every day this is a result of the
earth rotating through bulges of ocean
water formed by the gravitational
influence of the Sun and Moon we
experience greater tides called spring
tides when the Sun is aligned with the
moon allowing the gravitational
influence to combine this corresponds to
the new and full moon phases of the Moon
and we experience smaller tides and
smaller differences in high and low tide
during neap tides this occurs when the
moon is at 1/4 face offset to the Sun by
90 degrees meaning our tides are not
only smaller in total but the changes in
tide are minimized while their intensity
does vary these tidal changes come four
times a day and result in a flow of
water that will look something like this
for a spring tide and this for an ape
tied with the spring tide not only
resulting in a higher tide but a faster
flow of water which means more energy is
available for extraction these patterns
can be projected well into the future
thanks to the predictable movement of
the Sun Moon and Earth which definitely
cannot be said for the unpredictable
weather here on earth which affects wind
and solar energy despite the steady and
reliable flow of water ocean power
provides the smallest percentage of
renewable energy with only two
large-scale tidal energy plants a 240
megawatt system located in the ester e
of the Rance River in northern France
and a 254 mega watt system in Shi
Wallach in South Korea both our tidal
barrage systems which works similarly to
dams by opening and closing sluice gates
to control the flow of water through
their turbines this is a proven
technology proving they can generate
electricity and operate in sea water
without corrosion being a massive issue
thanks to cathodic protection so why are
there so few of these systems in the
world the problem is twofold first the
cost of installation is incredibly high
requiring a very large structure to
control the flow of water it simply
makes more sense to use other forms of
renewables like wind and solar and
second a large barrier like this has a
significant effect on the local
ecosystem one company Simek Atlantis is
looking to improve on both of these
points with their underwater turbines
which look remarkably like normal wind
turbines but thanks to waters higher
density can be much smaller their first
prototype system was placed here in the
mouth of Strangford Lough in Ireland
this area benefits from some
of the fastest flowing water in Ireland
as tides forced their way in and out of
the bottleneck of Strangford Lough
millions of tonnes of water flow through
the channel every day the system
consisted of two 16 metre diameter
turbines with a nameplate capacity of
0.6 megawatts each for reference an
equivalent wind turbine would have a
diameter of around 40 metres these
turbines reached full capacity in
November 2008 and were decommissioned in
May 2016 if that 1.2 megawatts ran
continuously at full capacity for all of
that time it would result in 77 to 79
gigawatt hours of power however it only
produced 11.6 gigawatt hours enough to
power around 1,000 American homes for
one year but that's just 15 percent of
its full potential that percentage is
called a capacity factor and 15 percent
is a very low capacity factor with
Ireland's five-year average wind energy
capacity factor standing around 28%
however this was a prototype which did
not run continuously and was routinely
taken offline for inspection and
research in their best month see Jen
produced 522 megawatt hours with a
capacity factor of 59% and see Jen claim
that that is reproducible year round
with a capacity factor of 59% year round
this would make tidal energy an
incredibly reliable energy source with
only minimal storage needed to smoothen
out the peaks and troughs between the
tides with a short time between peak
power generation and minimum power
generation this form of tidal energy
could use cheaper short-term energy
storage solutions like mechanical
batteries to create a desperately needed
renewable base load this project was
decommissioned in 2016 as part of the
research process it was vitally
important to test whether these machines
could be effectively removed from the
environment with minimal impact
this of course is a major concern for
anny machinery being placed into a
marine environment see Jen satisfied
this requirement having no significant
effect on the local ecosystem and they
have since moved on to the next stage of
their technology with major installed in
between the island of stroma and the
northeast coast of Scotland their
original lease agreement was for up to
400 megawatts provided the initial
testing phase with four turbines
satisfied the environmental impact
requirements the latest version of the
underwater turbine now has three turbine
blades allowing for an increase in
capacity to 1.5 megawatts with only a
slightly increased diameter turbine over
the 16 metre zero point five megawatt
turbines of their previous project in
Ireland this turbine is also completely
submerged so it is not an eyesore for
local residents see Jen previously had
actuators to lift the turbine out of the
water to allow maintenance to occur but
the new generation of turbines are
designed so the actual turbines and
generators can simply be placed and
removed from the substructure in about
30 minutes making installation and
maintenance vastly easier and cheaper
environmental impact has been a central
focus for the project and this started
with a comprehensive survey of the
surrounding ecosystem from seaweed and
shellfish to the whales that
occasionally visit the area the area
thankfully has such fast moving water
that the seabed was stripped of sand and
silt so the installation had little
impact on the ecology of the rocky sea
floor the impact the installation could
have on local marine mammals was of much
larger concern with surveys showing a
large population of boat seals and
dolphins with several haul out areas for
seals nearby both of these mammals are
sensitive to noise and will likely avoid
any area with excessive sound the noise
levels these turbines that miss is not
terribly high as they move relatively
slowly through the water
they're 544 page long environmental
report which I read to the best of my
ability
for the one week of research I did for
this video indicates that seals will
have a strong avoidance of the noise
within 38 metres of the structures while
mild avoidance may extend as far as a
hundred and sixty-eight meters with seal
howl outs over a kilometer away this was
deemed acceptable while dolphins are
expected to avoid the noise up to 100
meters and filter feeders like whales up
to 500 meters which may remove a small
section of sea from use but will not act
as a barrier to any significant feeding
ground a significant improvement over
tidal barrages this theory is backed up
by surveys conducted during CJ's
operation which found little evidence
that the two turbines had a significant
effect on the number of seals and
dolphins during operation but did have
an effect during the construction phase
where a noise was much higher area
avoidance would be useful in the fact
that it would prevent the animals from
straying too close to the turbines and
been struck by them potentially hurting
themselves and damaging the turbine once
again we can garner some positive data
from CJ which examined all carcasses
discovered near the site and found no
evidence that any deaths were caused by
impacts to the turbines this seems
unlikely but they theorized that these
animals actually avoid the area while
the turbine is operating
not because of sound but because the
water is flowing fast enough to make it
too difficult to swim and catch prey the
last major worry for these types of
devices is the fact that they need to
use toxic antifouling coatings to
prevent marine growth on the turbines
however Meijin uses a clever low
friction paint that self cleans as soon
as the marine growth grows large enough
where the drag overcomes their ability
to add ear to the slippery paint
additionally they trialed a sonar
detection system that would allow them
to track and potentially stop the
turbines when larger animals
occasionally passed through the area
without a doubt these types of turbines
would have less of an impact on the
environment than tidal barrages seen in
France and South Korea but only time
will tell whether this system in the far
reaches of Scotland will have a small
enough impact to encourage
systems to be installed cost will still
be a massive factor based on their
company's financial reports the mage end
project generated 2.7 million dollars of
revenue for the company in 2018 that's
0.67 million dollars of revenue for each
turbine based on their estimated cost
for a further forty nine turbines at
five hundred and forty million dollars
we can calculate that each would come
with an installation cost of around
eleven million dollars so that would
require sixteen point three years to
recoup the cost of installation which is
better than the twenty years it took to
recoup the cost of the tidal barrage
system in France and those numbers will
likely continue to drop if the company
manages to start manufacturing these
underwater turbines on a larger scale
plus it's slow going iterating and
improving on designs for tidal power is
much more difficult than other forms of
renewable energy testing has to take
place in coastal waters most of which
are public spaces requiring extensive
permitting and testing it's unlikely
that these underwater turbines will ever
compete on cost with onshore wind
turbines or solar but thanks to the
predictability of the tides this form of
energy could provide a reliable base
load when combined with low-cost
batteries if this project succeeds it
could justify large-scale manufacturing
of these turbines and transform tidal
energy from a small niche industry to a
huge player in the renewable energy
industry after all Meijin is just one
small section of a larger 1,600 megawatt
ocean energy project earmarked for
Pentland Firth and Orkney with mixes of
both wave and tidal energy a colossal
amount of energy which could go a long
way to diversifying Scotland's power
usage and we will delve into the world
of wave energy in a future video in the
meantime you can learn more about other
forms of renewable energies like solar
by watching some of my past videos on
the topic or taking this course on solar
energy on brilliant or even better mark
off one of your Christmas gifts and give
the gift of lifelong learning to one of
your loved ones
by gifting them a brilliant premium
subscription if you know anyone who has
a passion for math and science this is a
great gift that will nurture their
curiosity build confidence and help
develop vital problem-solving skills
crucial for school job interviews and in
their career brilliance
thought-provoking content breaks up
complexities into bite-sized
understandable chunks that will lead
them from curiosity to mastery this
obviously works because I had someone
from Tesla contact me this week tell
Amin they took this course in solar
energy in preparation for an interview
for Solar City if I have inspired you go
to brilliant org ford slash real
engineering and grab a gift subscription
to help your loved one spark a lifelong
love of learning as always thanks for
watching and thank you to all my patreon
supporters if you'd like to see more
from me the links to my Instagram
Twitter subreddit and discord server are
below
you